do you support more children going back
to primary school from tomorrow no we
think tomorrow is too soon and we have
made that argument very very clearly or
a number of well for a number of weeks
now essence Boris Johnson made his
announcement on the 10th of May and we
do think that schools are really
important
we know that vulnerable children need
get back to school and we don't know
that children need school for
socialization both physical health and
mental health so we're not making the
call that schools should not reopen
tomorrow
lightly we're doing it because we do not
believe the government's own tests have
been met and it is very complex and
difficult workings for them to do so
safely particularly with the guidelines
that the government has produced and you
say they're about the and I take your
point about the difficulty in socially
distancing it in schools but you make
the point there about how you don't take
this decision lightly because clue there
are negative consequences to children
being off school on last week's program
some I could Wilshire the former head of
Ofsted saying that we risk a lost
generation of youngsters are you worried
that you're not on the side of those
pupils who could be really put back by
spending months out of the classroom
members teachers and support staff have
really worked non-stop who try to
contact those children to try and get
the most vulnerable children into school
to provide learning at home I mean the
teachers and support staff and leaders
have done everything they and in this
pandemic to try to connect with those
children particularly the most
vulnerable children but actually you
know they got places in schools and many
of them are not taking them up because
the parents are scared about the Paras
and about being the very fact that
there's a huge thing to do also about
public confidence and parental
confidence that it is safe to get your
children back to school and the
government simply did not give enough
time to plan let me just give you one
one piece of information the
government's plans on reopening schools
since they were first produced on the
12th of May have been changed 41 times
and that's because it constantly had to
be revised as things they'd forgotten
things they didn't know things that got
wrong I've been added in that's hugely
added but the stress has school leaders
and teachers because we have a
government simply who they think it's
just making it up as it goes along and
you are talking about the fact that
schools can only go back when it's safe
to do so but if you look at the science
it does indicate that children are less
likely to get cope at 19 and also less
likely to pass it on UCL study for
example saying they're half as likely to
catch it adults the Italian town of beau
tested 86 6% of their population didn't
find a single child under 10 with kovat
and then also studies in the Netherlands
for example suggesting that by far
coronaviruses spread between adults or
from adults to children so if you're
talking about the science then doesn't
the science indicate that younger
children should be some of the first
people to be going back to school well
we know that well I absolutely the
science says that children do not get
the coat they might be they might get
infected but they don't get the disease
but actually the government itself its
own stage advises and Professor Pizza
jambe I'm gonna get his title right who
is on the stage committee and he's chair
of the government's new and emergency
this is a respiratory virus threats
advisory group and he said yesterday
that the government had a poor handle it
didn't know to what extent and whether
children transmit biron though that's
the government's own key adviser in
charge of its Committee on respiratory
diseases and we are asking teachers and
support staff because the government's
given up on social distancing in schools
it talks about cohort distancing so
there's a 15 children in a class with a
teacher but five or six hours a day
those children live in families who from
tomorrow will be able to go out and
socialize with six other people or
asking them without PPE and without
social distancing to go into schools at
a time when the rate of infection is
still the fifth highest incidence in the
world and at a time when there is not a
fully functioning test contact trace and
isolate system in place now we are
not saying because you can't eliminate
risk that schools should never be open
but we do agree with professor Hornby
and with independents say who say it
could keep a lot done there he's in
place for two more weeks and open
schools on June 15 then the rates of
infection in children will occur and
therefore their ability to pass on the
virus will have half we think that he's
safer we think that he's sensible we
think that's rational we think that's
responsible um do you think in that case
that if you are calling for the opening
of schools to be delayed a little bit
longer do you think that really the
summer holidays should be canceled to
allow children to catch up we think that
there should be activities for children
in the summer but with GCC that the
thing is this this this notion arts
media at schools have been closed that's
not been the case also been opened but
key workers and wonderful children and
in addition I I accept that schools have
been open but the question is
specifically a holiday be canceled to
allow children to catch up who've been
out of school for months no teachers
have been working with plateaux and to
provide education for children at home
so what should happen is and we do
support this and to have clubs and
activities on the volunteer basis for
those children to meet together to
socialize because what those children
have to do we don't get the embassy
should be on capture many of those
children will not need to resocialize
re-engage re-engage with learning and a
love of learning and being defaulting
creative activities which enable them to
become part of a wider society again and
have the desire to learn again we think
that when for at because the point is
this education is not going to get back
to normal not just a week but for a long
time yet and we have to build a new
national plan for education at school
for part of the time and at home part of
the time the government needs to make
sure that vulnerable children have
internet access
it needs a national plan for distance
and blended learning and at the moment
all these centers on schools who will
not be able to open to all pupils in
anytime soon is it is not taking this
account what is really needed and I
absolutely accept that teachers have
been working very hard to provide online
lesson some teacher
been going to school to provide
education for key workers children and
vulnerable children but at the same time
many people have been working flat out
throughout the corona virus pandemic
children have been off school for months
on end but we already are hearing
concerning stories about fears that some
of the progress with disadvantaged
children is going to be wiped out some
people listening to you saying that the
school holidays shouldn't be canceled
we'll be thinking why on earth not what
I think allowances that question already
teachers work the most unpaid overtime
of any profession many are exhausted
already and they need a holiday to
recover and the Secretary of State
himself has said that in the House of
Commons one of the few things that I
agree with governor Williamson on that
teachers should not be but we do support
activities for children over the summer
holidays and I think I've given a full
answer about what we do support ok after
his teachers have been working they've
been working extremely hard many
teachers have been working harder even
then they do normally now just to finish
now of course you've been involved in
the you trade union movement for many
years so I'm assuming that you had some
dealings with Dominic Cummings when he
was working in the Department for
Education Fiat from your knowledge of
him are you surprised by Boris Johnson's
decision to stand by him he's clearly an
integral part of a damaged Street
machine well I don't think I'd be
surprised by anything that boys Johnson
did and it's clear that Dominic Cummings
is essential to the Danny Street machine
and I think the boys Johnson is just
shown he's completely this is alienated
young party he's trashed the trust of
the public by publicly supporting and
defending to the hill someone who
clearly broke the lockdown rules and
clearly behaved in a reckless way my
knowledge Adamic